[Musique]
quels mets toi chez on dirait que la
petite veut ça m'a mis des frais c'est
pas la peine
la réception est hyper mauvaise
on peut la reprendre mais je sais
j'exagère résume
[Musique]
il est épris d'art c'est une propriété
privée
[Musique]
il faut quoi ils font rien
je pense que si ces barges au rite est
sérieux il nous aurait déjà attaqué
regardez ces bords attendant le massacre
bien tranquille qu'est ce que tu as fait
où est le bébé
avec mes frères et soeurs on veut tous
les bébés qu'on peut trouver
ce sont eux l'avenir après tout
le show avec vous et ne s'arrêteront pas
115 104
mais papa on va tout s'en sortir je te
le promets